so the other day I heard this acoustic
cover of post Malone's
chemical and I thought it was beautiful
so I wanted to make something similar
but I don't know how so I visited my
friend Corey you're going to be here
yeah that's crazy uh
hi nice to see you in person I'm Cory
and I'm a music producer and I asked him
if he could help okay so we're looking
to make a song similar to a song like
the same Vibe same energy Mission
understood so I played the song for him
so he could take a listen and figure out
what makes this song So
[Music]
Beautiful he's using a c which makes the
guitar sound really pretty when you're
playing it higher and then the
arrangement is acoustic guitar which is
going into this giant Reverb and his
voice is going into this giant Reverb
which creates this huge atmosphere and
then when the chorus comes in a bass
guitar comes in and then some big washed
out backing vocals come in let's do it
it's that easy sounds easy so I asked
him if he thought we'd be able to make
our song in 90 minutes or less I think
we can make at the very least a budget
version in 90 minutes good enough with
time taking down quickly he grabbed an
acoustic guitar and got to
work the very first thing he played
sounded really good so I asked him how'd
you do that I'm on the fifth fret doing
a 456 which
is which is just like the easiest way to
make something sound emotional whenever
it comes to like writing a song you
really don't want to overthink it so you
want to kind of just get like struming
pattern and like two chord progressions
and just start building from
[Music]
there and then I think for the chorus
that's where we'll hit the minor so it
adds that like
[Music]
depth sounds like a song to me let's uh
tune this guitar up and hit record and
attempt to play it good enough no I'm
sitting there you're hey I'm so sorry it
was not okay but it was time to record
and we started with the acoustic guitar
we're going to use this real microphone
so I'm going to use these headphones cuz
they're closed back so you don't hear
anything so it's completely isolated so
there's no bleed going into the
microphone okay that feels good so we're
going with 121 normally when you open a
session it defaults to 120 that's basic
we're going to throw a microphone here
I'm going to sit roughly a foot away
from it when you're recording acous
guitar uh if you record closer to the
hole here you'll get more low end if you
essentially move the microphone this way
you'll get less low end less body and
what you're going for is a balance the
only other thing I got to do is I got to
tune this
guitar there we go headphones so I can
hear the click track you can throw this
cable behind your shoulder cuz when
you're
recording you don't want that to happen
and then another thing you don't want to
do is you don't want to tap your foot
cuz if I tap the foot I'm moving the mic
stand I want to switch over to a thinner
pick and the reason for it is it'll go
through the strings easier and I'll have
less of that raiky like this has a
little bit more you got to like push it
through the strings more where I want to
get like as soft and sweet as I can it
will also help control the Dynamics so
it won't be like loud and quiet it'll
make it a little bit more even
[Music]
overall okay that was good enough so for
the chorus I'm just changing up the
chord progression in the verses I'm just
going back between the two chords but
I'm not hitting a minor chord so by
starting the chorus on a minor it just
like as that emotional weight that's
what you want for these indie songs
right someone's crying in their shower
is the vibe next Cory tossed on some
effects we're going to have like one
Central Reverb and the acoustic guitar
is going to send to it and the vocals
will send to it and everything else will
send to it what that does is it creates
the illusion of like a uniform space
everything is in that same space if we
listen that's my acous
[Music]
guitar wow then he did some EQ magic
that I didn't quite understand so ask
him to explain when you're eqing
eqing what is EQ all of that low end
will occupy space other instruments
should be occupying so you might not
hear by itself but once you throw
everything in Everything feels like it's
on top of each other so I'm making room
and on that note so let's not think too
hard let's record bass which apparently
not even the guitar wanted to hear yeah
I just do with the earplug so if I try
and hit the string they're muted so
then I mute everything I'm not playing
and there's no chance it can r ring out
and then I just get this perfect
[Music]
recording we good I love recording Bas
cuz it's that easy so true and just like
that the last element for the
instrumental is we are going to record
electric guitar and we're going to kind
of make it sound lap Steeles by playing
Super reverby notes that are super
sustained and just bending them I'm
going to grab at Guitar what are we at
time wise 41 minutes 41 minutes I've
recorded aous guitar and Bas wow that's
value I'm going to mute all of these
annoying strings that I don't want to
use those won't ring out and then I
can and I'm going to roll down my tone
knot here a little
bit there we go so that's going to make
it sound a little warmer a little
farther away and I'm going to just like
feel it
[Music]
out let me D back the botum here
and then Cory did some more EQ stuff
that I still didn't understand what is
EQ all that was left so are we going to
come up with lyrics yes so then we got
to work writing lyrics about the
universe
and good enough so with less than 30
minutes to go it was time to sing and
sing We Did
and Cory added in the electric guitar
flourishes we were done but what did
Corey think inspiring to write a song in
this way where you have defined
guidelines but I think it yielded
something that is pretty cool and I
think you're pretty cool Corey so if you
want to go listen to the song it's
available everywhere if you want to work
with Cory I'll leave a link to down
below and thanks for watching
[Music]